hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
Dishonored
the final episode I think he may be
alright it's been a long time because of
the whole computer crash thingy but now
I am back in it to win it and I am going
to finish this game once and for all
no matter how long it takes cuz I know
you guys have been waiting for it for a
long time and I know you probably
watched other people played or played it
for yourself but I don't care I'm gonna
kill this last rat bastard I'm gonna
kill him so dead I'm gonna kill him so
hard you're never gonna know it where it
came from except he is gonna know
because it came from my knife into his
neck not a euphemism okay
carrying on um I don't see anybody in
here is weird he has two ties yes he
does he had what's blood blood why's her
blood in here what's going on this seems
awfully suspicious hmm something's up
something's up I can tell because where
is he why is there blood everywhere what
is going on huh Corvo couldn't grateful
for me thank you thank you you're
welcome I'm glad that somebody
appreciates this I'm still gonna kill
you dead I'm still gonna murder you
harder than you've ever been murdered
before but at least you're appreciative
what oh oh no you don't oh no oh oh what
are you do not you do not what was that
optional objective I didn't see that
eliminate oh hell yeah I'm gonna
eliminate him cuz that's basically what
I've been doing this whole game so I'm
gonna eliminate him so hard
mmm nah but waiting for this he doesn't
even know he doesn't even know man oh
don't call her stupid that's my daughter
question mark
kill you so hard Lulu Lulu link anyway
and then Oh what did you blow up ah [ __ ]
him off ah Wow sorry you had to see that
little girl see you okay now I'm in time
engage yay yay I'm a good dad person
thank you yeah kinda ha ha that's my
girl
oh yeah you are I'm guessing that I have
influenced her in sadistic fashion I
guess I shouldn't be so happy about you
know driving a little girl the cruelty
that son that seems pretty mean
oh well that's my playthrough V and
health other yeah well what's this who
didn't honor that the daughter of a
murdered Empress ascended the throne up
a mountain of corpses uh-huh carried by
an assassin named Corvo ah ha ya know
huh
they'll say that little Emily called
when the first came to power in an age
of terror and corruption uh-huh that she
did her best
oh yeah that is not kind to little girls
or Empress's no not really
whoa
this doesn't look any good sorry lady oh
no oh no not them no survived man you're
kind of a dick to me but I'll admit I
was kind of a dick to everybody else
mention you by name or not she will
remember you were there ah why am i dead
are you old now okay hmm interesting you
know I wanted to learn more about this
other world that's they got going on
here I mean there's got to be a lot of
interesting backstory whoo ha ha ha ha I
was literally five minutes from the end
you got to be kidding me I was that
close man Wow all I gotta say is that is
an incredible game I mean I love I
absolutely love an original story I
really do it's um you don't see it a lot
these days especially not in movies but
definitely not as much in games as you
used to you see all these sequels you
see all these ohm additional sequels you
rehashes and games that are focused more
on multiplayer and I don't know about
you but I'm not the biggest multiplayer
guy I love to get engaged in a good
story and I hope you all don't feel bad
about me getting the bad ending I'm sure
there's a worse ending that you could
get but um don't feel bad about that I
wanted to play it like that just to have
some fun and I have an idea that most of
you who want to play the game the
quote-unquote correct way which there
isn't and that's another thing I like
about games like this but if you did
want to play it the correct way that way
I didn't spoil the ending for you and
there's something for you guys to find
out for yourself now I am sorry that
this took so long I mean a couple weeks
and delay between the last episode which
is only 5 minutes and 30 seconds long by
this count right now I mean I'm I feel
bad about that but that's the way it
goes sometimes given that I've never
played the game before and I don't know
where the ending is I know feeling it
was close I didn't know it was that
close so
I really do appreciate you guys sticking
with me for this long and I really do
appreciate Arkane Studios for making
such an incredible game I mean I don't
even know if there is a multiplayer in
this game but that's okay because this
game stands on its own it stands on its
own legs and it has such an incredible
art direction and style and a big
gigantic universe is completely new
there is so much potential to explore in
this universe I mean how did the plague
start how is the plague going to be
resolved how are things going to go into
the future the city that we operate in
is only one city in a giant world so I
would love love to see more coming along
in the future because I mean this is
great this was an incredible story and
the art was great made on the Unreal
Engine so thank you Arkane Studios for
making it thank you everybody out there
for watching and thank you so much for
just sticking with me I like doing these
non horror Let's Plays because I feel
that it allows me to get a bit more
creativity in my narration and
commentary and I don't know if you all
care about what I do but I have a
passion for gaming it as a whole and I
have a passion for anyone that tries to
do something original like you all know
me I could talk for hours about this but
I'm gonna cut it short and just say
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for more videos than
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
I must come over that's ridiculous